well it has been a very consequential 24
hours for uh donald trump for
the justice department for the january
6th committee we have so many pieces of
breaking news to talk about and i want
to start first and foremost with a
federal judge's opinion that donald
trump likely committed multiple felonies
in trying to overturn the results of the
2020 election now we're going to talk
about what this means and what it
doesn't mean and many of you rightly
writing to me correctly writing to me
and saying david wait a judge determines
whether trump is guilty doesn't a jury
do that
this is not a determination of
criminality for the purposes of
punishment donald trump has not been
charged the context here is evidence and
does there
appear to be
a legitimate reason
to turn over certain records on the
basis that it seems reasonable
that donald trump committed crimes and
thus the evidence is
legitimate to be looked at by
investigators and we're going to talk
about that and we have some very um
specific comments about this from legal
experts let's start with the new york
times article federal judge finds trump
most likely committed crimes over the
2020 election the judge wrote in a civil
case the illegality of the plan was
obvious
separately the january 6th panel voted
to recommend contempt of congress
charges for two former trump aides
this article is worth reading in its
entirety the important points here a
federal judge ruled yesterday that trump
and a lawyer who advised him on how to
overturn the 2020 election
most likely had committed felonies
including obstructing the work of
congress and conspiring to defraud the
united states
the judge's comments on the civil case
of the lawyer john eastman marked a
significant breakthrough for the house
committee investigating the riots the
committee is weighing making a criminal
referral
to the justice department had used the
filing in the case to lay out the crimes
it believed trump might have committed
importantly trump has not been charged
with any crime the judge's ruling has no
immediate practical legal effect on him
but it ratifies the committee's argument
that trump's efforts to block congress
from certifying biden's win
could well rise to the level of a
criminal conspiracy
this is we we can't let this be
normalized
it is outrageous that this is what is
going on judge david carter wrote
quote the illegality of the plan was
obvious our nation was founded on the
peaceful transition of power epitomized
by george washington laying down his
sword to make way for democratic
elections ignoring this history
president trump vigorously campaigned
for the vice president to
single-handedly determine the result of
the 2020 election so what are our
questions here well the first question
is does this
finally
give the attorney general merrick
garland
a way to move forward
with the criminal charges and the answer
is it probably does but he probably
won't
now what's really important to
understand here is
what does this mean this is not a judge
ruling
that a crime was committed
that's for a jury to do if charges are
brought but i asked former fbi special
agent who's now a lawyer asha rangapa
she teaches at yale law school i asked
her about this on twitter and she
explained very clearly quote the judge's
opinion
isn't itself evidence of a crime it's an
evaluation of some of the evidence
which is the grand jury's job
i'd say at most it suggests that a grand
jury would be able to independently find
probable cause to charge but the problem
is proving it beyond a reasonable doubt
to a jury
asha went on to add the judge may have
just been stating what was obvious from
the evidence but no doubt it's a major
flag
that this had better be an active
department of justice investigation
dereliction of duty if it is not so this
is the main point and we've been talking
about this for some time
i don't think anybody is arguing now let
me put it a different way
due process holds
that
one is innocent until proven guilty and
due process holds that we can't say
someone should be punished for a crime
until they've been found guilty of a
crime and right now donald trump has not
even been charged so we're
you know the right loves to say they're
all about law and order but they will
immediately suspend due process when
they want someone quote locked up think
hillary clinton we're not going to do
that we're going to stick to due process
but what is abundantly clear at this
point
is we have endless opinions including
now from a federal judge
that it's at least quite plausible
that felonies have been committed and so
what does that mean it doesn't mean you
throw someone in jail after before
getting a guilty verdict but it does
mean there should be an active
investigation and asharangapa is
completely correct about that so this
ruling affects a very specific part of
the process of investigation it relates
to a civil case it's not time for jail
we're not saying lock anybody up it's
the right that loves to do that by
skipping due process but what we are
saying is if there's no investigation
going on right now
it raises some major major questions
that we need to have answered and
unfortunately
what we saw in manhattan
is very similar to this remember that
mark pomerantz and another prosecutor
investigating trump criminally in
manhattan resigned
and initially many on the right were
saying they resigned because they knew
that it was all bogus and there was
nothing to investigate no
we speculated and it's since been
confirmed
they resigned because they actually
thought wow trump did commit crimes
and it doesn't seem there's any interest
in actually charging him and so our work
is essentially being done for nothing we
found evidence of criminality nobody's
interested in charging the guy i'm out
of here that's what happened so we're
seeing the same story
federal judge
civil case manhattan investigators
everybody coming to the conclusion
felonies were probably committed here
will he be charged i'm not i'm not
particularly optimistic
this is just an unbelievable story
after months and months of wrangling
trying to avoid providing call records
to the house committee investigating the
january 6 trump riots
the trump white house the former white
house
finally provided the call records to the
january 6th committee great right i mean
what delightful we they've got the
information they need
no
the january 6th call logs provided by
trump to the committee
have a seven hour gap
on january 6th the key hours
during which it is crucial and critical
to understand who is trump speaking to
now there's a second layer to this which
is
they may have had phone calls that they
never put in the log so there's kind of
two layers of accountability the first
is give us the log so we can see who you
spoke to that assumes the logs are
accurate
and i would not assume that with this
former administration
but the next part of it is of course
well
do the calls even reflect what what they
should reflect um washington post report
very good report by bob woodward and
robert costa january 6 white house logs
given to the house
show a seven-hour gap
wow
the house select committee is now
investigating whether it has the full
record
and whether trump communicated that day
through back channels phones of aids or
personal disposable phones now trump is
claiming he doesn't know what a burner
phone is i don't believe that for a
second we're gonna get to that in a
moment read the whole article we're
linking to it
internal white house records from the
day of the attack that were turned over
to the house select committee show a gap
in trump's phone logs of 7 hours and 37
minutes including
what a surprise the period when the
building was being violently assaulted
according to documents obtained by the
washington post and cbs news the lack of
an official white house notation of any
calls placed to or by trump for 457
minutes
look at the time here from 11 17 a.m to
6 54 p.m trying to think what was going
on during that time oh right that was
exactly when the capital was taken over
by
violent insurrectionists attempting to
overturn the results of the election
well during that time we don't have the
logs
that means the committee has no record
of his phone conversations as his
supporters descended on the capitol
battled overwhelmed police and forcibly
entered the building prompting lawmakers
and vp mike pence to flee for safety the
11 pages of records which consist of the
president's official daily diary and the
white house switchboard call logs were
turned over by the national archives
earlier this year the records show trump
was active on the phone for part of the
day documenting conversations with at
least eight people in the morning and
eleven in the evening
but there is this seven hour gap that
stands in stark contrast to the
extensive public reporting about phone
calls he had with allies during the
attack we know he spoke to mike lee he
spoke to tommy tuberville he spoke to
kevin mccarthy and many others so in
essence they didn't really turn over the
records
uh in that
we don't actually have the records or
the white house doesn't uh during those
key moments now i want to talk about
this burner thing this is now from a cbs
news article remember that this was a
kind of joint report from washington
post and cbs
the house panel is now investigating
whether trump communicated through back
channels meaning he could have used
other people's phones or personal
disposable phones known as burner phones
look at this in a statement monday night
trump said i have no idea what a burner
phone is to the best of my knowledge i
have never even heard the term
does anybody believe that
does anybody believe that donald trump
doesn't know what a burner phone is i
know he's not the brightest
but there is no doubt that he knows what
a burner phone is the stuff that trump
has been up to for so long
now um is it possible he doesn't know it
by that name he knows it as a disposable
phone
i i don't know guys maybe maybe but this
is not believable
and when we talk about
remember when we spoke about the ukraine
fiasco that led to the second
impeachment remember when we spoke about
the entire russia probe quite frankly as
i've said before
if from the beginning of the suspicions
about russia the mueller investigation
the entire thing
much of what took place was
self-inflicted harm done by trump
if trump hadn't gone public and tweeted
all sorts of things that attracted more
attention to the story if trump hadn't
gone overboard in his denials and then
it came out actually they met with all
of these russian uh uh individuals and
all these different things
the investigation would never have
become what it was and similarly when it
comes to january 6th it is increasingly
plausible
that
had trump just cooperated
uh and not called attention to the fact
that he's obviously trying to cover up
the full scope of what he did and what
he said and who he spoke to that day
this also likely would not be as big as
it is
because to be perfectly frank my opinion
is
whatever is in those missing seven and a
half hours
it's probably not good
but if you don't have the contents of
those calls you have a circumstantial
case at best most likely and again the
fact that there is a seven and a half
hour gap in the records at exactly the
key time that's being investigated is
just putting more of a focus on that
time and suggesting that donald trump
knows
that he did something wrong so
i'm not suggesting trump is innocent but
what i am suggesting is that the
cover-up after the fact actions
are putting more of a spotlight when you
don't give seven and a half hours of
logs you're saying these are the seven
and a half hours that you want to focus
on now unfortunately and i know we
continue to have this discussion you and
i uh in the audience
uh it's not looking to me like there are
going to be any consequences here number
one there seems to be no willingness on
the part of any prosecutor to actually
look at criminal charges for any of
what's taken place and number two
listen
trump is pretty teflon it's just the
reality and uh he's thinking about
running again in 2024 there's the
possibility that even running again may
be part of keeping himself out of
trouble trouble by being back in power
uh and i'm i remain
pessimistic about uh accountability here
but in the last 24 hours just incredible
stories and a seven and a half hour gap
in the phone records if you believe that
we are finally getting to where it's
overwhelming there are going to be
consequences
let me know you can find me on twitter
at dpakman and let me know what you
think is coming
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is primarily made
possible by viewers and listeners like
you who sign up on our website for the
membership program we do an extra show
every day for our members and i would
love for you to sign up you know we very
often kind of don't even think about the
fact that we contribute a few bucks a
month to all sorts of channels whose
politics we may not agree with if you
have a cable tv subscription you are
contributing a few bucks a month to some
channels i guarantee you you don't like
um and we should think about
contributing a couple bucks to programs
we actually do like and want to support
and you can do that by signing up at
joinpackman.com
and you can use the coupon code wow 22
to get a discount i want to talk about
um
sort of a media story that's been
created out of something that joe biden
recently said which i agree with
completely
and i believe that it's being
deliberately misinterpreted the other
day joe biden said
putin can't remain in power putin can't
remain in power
and joe biden was correct and what joe
biden obviously meant when he said it
was
this guy's a disaster
this guy's terrible for his own people
this guy has invaded another country and
is leading to the deaths of i don't even
want to say whether it's thousands or
tens of thousands or i mean we just
don't know right now the amount of death
that is being caused by the russian
invasion of ukraine and joe biden said
this guy can't remain in power and joe
biden was not saying we're going to
invade russia joe biden was not saying
we're going to assassinate putin joe
biden was not saying we're going to
affect regime change in russia he wasn't
saying any of those things now has the
u.s done things like that in the past of
course
but it's not what joe biden said and
it's very clearly not what joe biden
meant i agree putin can't remain in
power but it's it's not up to us to take
him out of power but putin can't remain
in power it would be better for the
world for putin not to be in power it'd
be better for the world for rodrigo
duterte not to be in power
uh it'd be better for kim jong-un not to
be in power
uh bolsonaro maduro i mean there's lots
of leaders where i would say
this guy can't remain in power this is
not good but that's different than we're
going to take them out or u.s
imperialism is going to affect regime
change or any of those things well
yesterday joe biden did an event where
he announced his uh new budget and
billionaire tax that we spoke about on
the bonus show he took about 10 or 11
questions from reporters
and almost all of them were versions of
the same question
wasn't it wrong for you to suggest
you're going to take putin out and of
course that's not what joe biden said so
let's look at some of these examples and
this is a perfect example of i know that
these reporters understand
that's not what joe biden meant joe
biden didn't say i want to invade russia
i want to remove putin i want to
assassinate putin or any of these things
joe biden just said this guy can't
remain in power for the good of the
world oh and i even lost my headphones
because i'm gesticulating so wildly so
let's start with the first one here here
is a kelly o'donnell from nbc
kelly o'donnell nbc
thank you mr president do you believe
what you said
thank you sir do you believe what you
said that putin can't remain in power or
do you now regret saying that because
your government has been trying to walk
that back does your words complicate
matters
well you ask three different questions
i'll answer them all number one i'm not
walking anything back
the fact of the matter is i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
toward the way putin is
dealing and the actions of this man
just just
brutality
half the children in ukraine i just come
from
being with those families
and
and so uh but i want to make it clear i
wasn't then nor am i now articulating
the policy change i was expressing the
moral outrage that i feel and i make no
apologies for it
my personal feelings
secondly you asked me about uh
well what was the second part complicate
the diplomacy of this moment no i don't
think it does you know the the uh
uh
the fact is that we're in a situation
where uh
um
what complicates the situation at the
moment is the
uh the escalatory
efforts of putin
to uh continue and engage in carnage the
kind of behavior that uh
that makes the whole world say
all right so i think you get the point
he's not saying there's a new policy
he's not saying we're invading russia
he's not saying any of those things he's
just like this this guy can't remain in
power and this is really one of those
cases where
uh media is seizing on something and
there's really nothing there next we'll
go to peter ducey from fox
who uh by the way for
for all of the adversarial questions
that peter ducey asks joe biden keeps
calling on him at almost every press
avail uh let's listen thank you thank
you very much i know you're gonna ask a
really nice question well it's it's an
important question i think are you
worried that other leaders in the world
are gonna start to doubt that america is
back if some of these big things that
you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back then watch can you walk back
they made it sound like just in the last
couple days uh it sounded like you told
us troops they were going to ukraine it
sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about
helping train the troops in that are the
the ukrainian troops that are in poland
that's with the context i sat there with
those guys for a couple hours that's
what we talked about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with speeding with
and talking with the uh ukrainian troops
who are in poland and when you said a
chemical weapon used by russia would
trigger a response in kind
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
why would i tell you you got to be silly
okay so that's on the first two points
and then biden again going on to address
this question of regime change regime
change you were calling for regime
change and of course he was not and
every reporter asking this they it's
like they they smelled blood in the
water and they could ask nothing else
back to your original words that he
cannot remain in power
can you help us understand you have more
foreign policy experience than any
president who's ever held this office
right
whether those are your personal feelings
or your feelings as president do you
understand why people would believe you
as someone commanding one of the largest
nuclear arsenals in the world saying
someone cannot remain in power is a
statement of u.s policy and also are you
concerned about propaganda use of those
remarks by the russians
no and no
tell me why you have so much experience
you are the leader of this country
because it's ridiculous
nobody believes we're gonna take down i
was gonna i was talking about taking
down putin
nobody believes that
number one number two and i think he's
right that even these reporters don't
believe it i don't think these reporters
really believe biden was saying we're
gonna go in and take putin out and do
regime change he just said this guy
can't stay in power
what have i been talking about
off since this all began
the only war that's worse than one
intended is one that's unintended the
last thing i want to do is engage in a
land war or nuclear war with russia
that's not part of it i was expressing
my outrage as the behavior of this man
all right so you guys get it and this is
the perfect story of the media-driven
narrative when joe biden said this had
reporters not started going crazy saying
sir are you demanding regime change it
never would have become a story there's
plenty to criticize joe biden about uh
this is not it and uh it's almost a
signal as to i mean listen it wasn't
even a slow news week and yet still
seven out of the ten questions or
something were focused on this very
strange stuff and not particularly
informative to the american public i
want to do a little bit of a follow-up
about the will smith slap of chris rock
during the oscars on sunday night
the american right wing
seems to have lost its mind and are
delivering
bizarre
take after take
about what happened or what didn't
actually happen on sunday night now i'm
going to talk a little bit
in a little bit
about kind of what my my now having had
a chance to think about it more
what my view is on what happened on
sunday night for those of you who don't
know chris rock during the oscars made a
joke about will smith's wife's short
hair
which is um
the style she chooses because she has
alopecia of baldness
and will smith didn't like it and he
walked up to chris rock during the
oscars and slapped him in the face and
then yelled keep my wife's name out of
your mouth it was an insane situation
and i'm going to talk about my thoughts
in a moment but first let me show you
some just bizarre takes
cultural critic and arbiter of ideas
dave rubin um
said that
if it had been a white person who did
the slap
then everybody would have gone crazy and
he's mad about that so he's upset about
how people would have reacted in a
different situation
what are you even talking about dude um
but but because they know no one's
paying attention would you put it above
the machinery of hollywood what to
fabricate something like this that that
chris rock makes a fairly innocuous joke
i mean she's got a shaven head and i'll
talk more about alopecia in a sec as i
said um and that will smith so loses
control he's laughing at the joke at
first that he so lost control of himself
that on an evening where he knows
millions even though it's not as many
millions as it used to be millions of
people are watching that he so lost
control of himself that he walks up on
stage comment he didn't bum rush the
stage right he walks up there smacks the
guy and just sits down no security came
and got him so far he's spot on i like
this analysis so far
uh nobody you know apparently during the
commercials there were some pr people
saying something to him um but you know
we could also add like the weird woke
element of race to this so it was black
on black violence which people obviously
treat a little bit differently i suspect
that woke element what if matt damon had
gotten out of the crowd very pasty white
matt damon had gotten out of the crowd
and smacked chris rock we'd be there
would be riots in the streets okay so
now it's just completely unhinged yeah
it's it's not going to be if it was matt
damon who slapped chris rock you were
not going to see the rodney king riots
or anything like that so the with the
woke aspect of this just a bizarre take
he's mad about how people would have
reacted to something that didn't happen
how is that a story then we go to fox
news where donald trump's former press
secretary kaylee mcinanny
uh compared what happened
to when michelle wolf joked about sarah
huckabee sanders and right wingers were
mad and it has nothing to do with it
whatsoever would have stopped him i
would hope but because he's will smith
they just don't yeah i think trace made
the key point you know if it was a fan
it'd be totally different treatment than
it would be for a celebrity and also i
think very different scenario when you
think too i couldn't get out of my head
as i watched this the white house
correspondents association dinner from
2018 where sarah sanders was so
maliciously attacked um you had samantha
samantha wolf or b whatever the heck her
name is michelle wolf going after sarah
sanders for her appearance and minutes
long excruciating detail and i watched
sarah sanders sit there my predecessor
with such grace and poise and kindness
and just sit there and take it because
if you're a republican woman
you got to take it if you're a celebrity
you engage in this behavior and you'll
have people come to your defense jamal
bowman another congressman came to the
defense of will smith you had a cnn
commentator who actually blamed this on
donald trump coming to will smith's
defense but if i just may make this one
ancillary point just like i didn't like
the jokes about sarah sanders i did not
like that joke about will smith's wife i
had a friend who uh i grew up with who
had alopecia and i just thought it was
totally out of bed okay so
again there it it really isn't uh
whatever point she's trying to make is
not landing and it's always somehow
about wokeness and people and
criticizing and double standards with
conservatives last clip here this is
sunny hostin from the view not a right
winger per se but sort of sometimes a
contrarian on that show or maybe
compared to the others in any case she
talks about um how this is a uh this was
an instance of toxic max masculinity and
i think that when that type of thing
when you live publicly
you don't have the right to all of a
sudden decide to
execute violence and i have to say that
was a show of toxic masculinity if he
was offended and felt emasculated by
regina hall's joke uh or by chris chris
rock's joke you don't act out in
violence that is not a show of love
that's a show of violence and i think
that um and then lastly kyle becker the
ceo of becker news a former fox news
producer tweeting if will smith was a
white guy he would have been let out of
the oscars in handcuffs then police
would have thrown him in jail there
would be a thousand media hit pieces
about him being racist he would be
canceled for life and steady won best
actor that's privilege and of course
that's also untrue uh chris rock
declined to press charges and that's
sort of it so
i have to tell you there are little
pieces of what these people said that
actually do make a lot of sense
what we have here was
maybe an a distasteful joke by chris
rock
and then a physical attack these are not
on the same playing field it it's will
smith is right to be completely
humiliated by what he did it's
embarrassing number one
number two
even if it indeed will smith was sort of
standing up for his wife
uh she was not in any kind of physical
danger right
physically slapping someone
would be legitimate to stand up for your
wife
if it's a defense to a physical attack
there was no physical danger and number
number three
it is notable that no security get
involved in any way now i know that it's
easy to say well security would never
think that will smith's gonna slap chris
rock there's no reason that they would
do that
okay but it is also kind of reflective
more generally of the academy staff did
nothing to prevent this in any way they
didn't make any effort to explain why
will smith stayed in the building after
a physical attack the physical attack is
completely out of bounds and as a big
will smith fan myself he should be
completely humiliated by what happened
here at the end of the day this whole
thing about well the joke was very off
color i don't disagree
the joke was off color you're sitting in
the front row at the oscars this is what
happens at the oscars there's a roast
element there's a roast aspect to this
these people make millions and millions
of dollars you can take a bad joke you
don't need to go and physically slap
someone and will smith is
unilaterally in the wrong there we'll
have these clips on our instagram at
david pakman davidpakmanshow where you
can also let me know your thoughts about
my analysis
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show today
we're going to be speaking with claudia
golden who's a professor of economics at
harvard university and author of the new
book career and family women's
centurylong journey toward equity uh
it's really great to have you on today i
appreciate your time
i'm pleased to be here
so i i think maybe to start our
conversation it might be interesting as
you catalog
in the book to talk about some of the
catalysts over the last hundred years
that have led women to enter the
workforce in greater numbers now that
than at any previous time can you talk a
little bit about kind of the main
highlights on these last hundred years
certainly so so to begin with
in fact the most important change in the
labor force in almost every country in
the world has been the increase
of women
in the workforce
so so this decision is sort of made by
considering
what we call the opportunity cost of
being in the household so when paid work
is more remunerative
it it's worth more relative to home
production you exit that household and
you go to work you know and this can
come about because real wages increase
it can also come about because household
production has better alternatives all
you have to think about
is what it would be like to bake bread
yourself rather than buying it of course
lots of people bake bread and they do a
very good job
but
and and it might also be furthered when
social norms and traditions change so
you asked about
uh the catalyst so technological change
of lots of different types did it
so the most important ones are the ones
that decreased the importance of what we
call brawn work now i'm really strong
i'm stronger than my husband i know but
there are a lot of men who are stronger
than i am
and it increased the value of brain work
that's really very important so
uh and then there are the technologies
that made homes cleaner and their care
less labor-intensive
you know we forget about the fact we
take for granted that we have clean
water and sewage removal we have flushed
toilets and central heating and
household electricity and finally there
are those that enabled women to control
their fertility it's really very very
important
and
that led to
an enormously large increase in the age
of first marriage in as late as the
1970s
when the birth control pill
finally diffused among among young women
so those are the main ones
you um have spoken about in in the new
book you talk about the significantly
increased rate of women who get college
degrees and at a very top level we know
that at least right now this may change
but at least right now people with
college degrees have higher lifetime
earnings can you talk a little bit about
the the educational component to this as
well
so i think that you're asking why it is
that women versus men
uh get more degrees so so the returns
are extremely high on the margin
uh all these you know the vast majority
of individuals who don't get a college
degree would do much better if they if
they did that's not true for everyone
but it's true on the margin
uh but first a few important facts that
are generally not known
there have been more female college
graduates in the u.s
than male college graduates
since around 1980 so therefore it didn't
happen yesterday it didn't even happen
10 years ago began believe it or not 40
years ago
the second fact of importance is that
when high school graduation was a really
important milestone
and when just 10 to 20 of the nation's
young
people would cross that threshold and i
mean like in the first quarter century
of the the the first quarter of the 20th
century
uh women were the vast majority of high
school graduates okay
that's an important fact and the third
fact is that there are more female than
male college graduates in virtually all
the rich countries in the world
and even in the poorer countries women
are increasing their numbers relative to
men
so we and to understand what's going on
we have to take all of this into
consideration so two facts or two
notions the first is that work for men
is still partially brawn driven so guys
can still do construction work go to any
construction site how many women do you
see very very few
and so men even without a college degree
can still find
uh work that we used to call good work
it's become less and less good although
the demand for
non-college graduates today is very hard
and the second point
is that men
let's call them males because most of
them are very young don't get their act
together until later in life
and this is reflected in just a host of
risky behaviors from drugs to crime to
those that result in their own bodily
harm and so those who study psychology
and genetics can point to some of the
underlying reasons and it means that the
boys don't write their college essays on
time and they don't apply on time and
they don't go
when we
talk about this issue with most
americans who are sort of centered in
the political debates of our time
a lot of the factors that you're talking
about to build up this foundation of our
understanding of the dynamics of the
workforce often get sort of tested by
the final output which is what does pay
look like and and questions of pay
disparity
and for a very long time this idea of
the 77 cents on the dollar was being
floated about
about eight years ago we did a kind of
deeper dive into this and and some of
your research was actually part of of
what we use to figure out what a maybe
more accurate number is and it seems
that the 77 cent number is simply not an
accurate number from what i'm recalling
now from the research it seemed to be
closer to 92 cents on the dollar
some part of which might be due to
discrimination can you talk a little bit
about that okay
okay i know this is a huge can of worms
i understand
as someone said a can of worms larger
than the universe which is a little
scary
so the first thing is that
first of all it's not 77 it's 82 i
believe
but it is an accurate number for
something everything's an accurate
number if i told you the price of apples
you know in the corner store that would
be an accurate number for the price of
apples at the corner store maybe not be
the correct number for the price of
apples in san diego or omaha
so that that's part of the issue so it
is constructed
by taking
everyone in the current population
survey
taking their weekly earnings
for men and women
and using only those who are full-time
year-round so that that sort of
standardizes in some manner not entirely
and then takes the median for women and
the median for men and divides that's a
number it's an accurate number for what
it's doing okay here's the inaccuracies
the inaccuracies are that
for each woman
the
amount that she receives relative to men
changes over her lifetime we know that
we know that for relatively young men
and women their earnings are pretty
similar you know if i look at what
happens to
college graduates or law school
graduates
when they first leave their earnings are
very similar
and then over time they diverge and they
diverge a tremendous amount for those
at the highest end the professionals so
lawyers so
two lawyers might both both go to a park
avenue law firm and then they marry they
have kids and they realize it's
unsustainable and so what happens is
that it's often the case that the woman
will
remain a lawyer
but move to a firm that's smaller and
less demanding less greedy
the difference between their earnings
that ratio isn't 77 it's not 92 it's
often 64. you know but we generally
don't observe in
census data
since we're
narrowing this we're looking at the
medians these are uh the very very upper
tail if we looked at the lower tail
then they're going to be far
more similar it's almost ironic i've
often been asked
isn't the gender gap wider at the bottom
and i said i'm going to be whiter at the
bottom we've got
a uh we've we've got a bottom that's
limited by the minimum wage so it's not
as if you have so much room at the
bottom you have a tremendous amount of
room at the top
and so that's that's the issue
so it is a correct number
but it's not a number that's going to
tell us a lot about what's happening
to
uh the uh individuals as they go through
their life cycle
that's very interesting so and with your
study being in economics
you're able to explore
a number of different ways of measuring
this depending on what is the question
that we are sort of trying to answer and
then it seems that a second layer on top
of this would be if one wants to ask
political questions or societal
questions about discrimination we need
to be very careful about
what are the numbers that we're
considering it sounds like
absolutely i mean it's my sense
that
there's no question that there are
disparities that we should eliminate
there's sexual harassment
there's uh disparities in terms of the
ability of individuals to go to a
supervisor and ask
for a raise there's real discrimination
but it's my
sense and we have a lot of information
that shows this that even if we
eradicated all of that and i hope we do
eradicate all of that it's not going to
close the gap because much of the gap is
due to this notion of greedy work and
the fact that in
couples that are different sex couples
they often abandon gender equity
as i just said with the couple who
graduated from law school and when they
abandoned couple equity they throw
gender equality under the bus with it
when you uh in the book talk about
various anti-discrimination laws
um training for people in managerial and
supervisory positions
my understanding and my reading of it is
you do find that these um
initiatives are valuable but that
they're not necessarily enough is that
fair
yeah i i would say that they're it's not
that they're not necessarily enough
they're not really getting to the main
problem
and when you if we really want to
fine-tune or ascertain
the problem it seems there's a number of
components to some degree i mean you
talked about the dynamic within opposite
sex couples and career choices that
exist there
you talked about the difference between
what we might consider
uh higher wage jobs rather than than
middle or lower wage jobs can you talk
to us about some of the other
specific points that should be looked at
when we are trying to identify exactly
what the problem to be addressed is
uh certainly uh so they the
problem in many ways
is that work
a lot of work is very greedy and so
when individuals
uh couples are making these choices
they can
and and they have care responsibilities
they can both take
the
more flexible
job that allows them to
respond to
emergencies that allows them a certain
amount of flexibility without penalty
but if they do that and the world is
very greedy they're leaving a lot of
money on the table it's it's really as
simple as that
um greedy jobs also impact those at the
lower end
but that's a somewhat different story
but it's it's the it it's really the
case
that for
uh many
uh couples uh they're faced with a
difficult problem as to whose career is
going to
get the upper hand let's say but at the
same time
there's no question that both members of
the couple lose out
because men lose out of the joys and and
of of seeing their family uh
in the same amount of time that women do
and women lose out because their careers
are
in many ways lowered and they're lowered
for their lifetimes
last thing i want to ask about programs
like universal pre-k
publicly funded child care etc it might
seem as though if these are
funded through taxes
and they provide both parents for lack
of a better term with a more equalizing
opportunity to remain in the workforce
in a more engaged way it would seem as
though programs like that might have an
equalizing force is is that the case
yeah so uh so let's think about it there
are three types of solutions
one is to lower the price of these
flexible jobs make them more productive
that that's the one that i that i
spend a lot of time on the second one is
to lower the price of care of of
children not just children but of the
elderly and we that's another set of
issues
and the third type of solution is simply
to change gender norms because
if in fact
when given this choice it was random
then you might throw couple equity under
the bus but you wouldn't throw gender
equality under the bus with it okay but
let's talk about you it's a somewhat
separate
issue to talk about universal pre-k and
publicly funded child care that would
certainly change the price of care it
would drive it down
relative to the amount that you get from
working
by the way
it would
also be the case that if we change tax
policy that might be a good thing to do
too so if we didn't have joint returns
as is the case in britain and sweden
uh then uh
uh women wouldn't uh
in some sense be faced within the family
by the higher
marginal
tax rate so that would be a very good
thing too
but the problem is that someone has to
pay for universal pre-k and child care
and the latter
child care is extremely expensive as
anyone with children knows i mean
everyone complains it's very interesting
that
everyone with children complains about
the high cost of child care
and at the same time they complained
that child care workers are paid too
little
so
right where do you think the costs come
from right
it's it's it's it's a very very simple
point if you have
one child care worker
for three children
just do the math and it's very very
clear that if you're actually if your
child care worker
is well educated well skilled and
well-paid it's going to cost a
tremendous amount so these are decisions
for the politics sweden decided that
they didn't want to go that route not
for infants by the way for infants they
the one of the parents
receives uh parental leave and is paid
for that
so as researchers though we can
demonstrate that pre-k
increases the human capital of the next
generation
reversal pre-k
you didn't say pre-k you said universal
and that's important by involving the
entire community
is actually more effective
than targeted pre-k
um so
so that's uh
sort of the answer
universal pre-k would be very very nice
i mean let's face it
we have public education
at what age should it begin
you know at some point in the 1920s
1930s it was decided that it we should
push it
to five
years old or six years old and have this
thing called kindergarten uh at some
point in the 20th century we had
universal kindergarten
so uh so there's no it's
this is a matter of the age uh
three-year-olds four-year-olds can learn
right and so
i guess
spoken as someone who has a
four-year-old
the new book is career and family
women's century-long journey toward
equity we've been speaking with the
book's author harvard university
economics professor claudia golden i
really appreciate your time and your
insights today
well thanks very much david i've enjoyed
it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
i want to do a kind of close the loop on
a story we've been covering which is
this u.s trucker convoy now you might be
saying david the trucker convoy wasn't
that like months ago in canada or did
the u.s convoy even actually get started
and you would be right to be confused
because they accomplished absolutely
nothing they got almost no attention
they were protesting non-existent
mandates and it is now coming to a close
this is i have to tell you
i love this i take so much pleasure in
this good daily beast report people's
convoy gives up and will leave dc after
three weeks of doing absolutely nothing
our friend zachary patrizo wrote this
for the daily beast
and he explains three weeks after the
so-called people's convoy landed in
washington dc the group is calling it
quits after accomplishing nothing except
injuring residents and circling the
beltway
co-organizer mike landis announced
sunday night that the group would pack
its things up in the coming days and
drive back to california
landis said the convoy goers who remain
in hagerstown maryland who had freezing
nights while camping out will enjoy a
southerly route back to california we're
going to take
a little more southern route so it's a
little warmer than this
um this is absolutely fantastic now a
lot of you were probably reacting by
saying i didn't even know that they were
still there and indeed they did nothing
now there's two there's two parts to
this the first part is even when the
canadian trucker convoy got going
they were mostly protesting non-existent
mandates
and um
uh
since then even more vaccine
requirements have been dropped now in
the united states the us trucker convoy
is quite literally protesting for
freedom that they have i mean there's
almost no vaccine requirements remaining
for people who are within the united
states if their own company requires
them to be vaccinated or tested
that's their company policy
the supreme court already said that joe
biden forcing companies with over 100
employees to require vaccination or
testing had to be halted so at its core
this was a movement about something that
is not actually a problem but the second
part of this that i find just
particularly funny is
these are people who were i don't want
to call it rallying they were basically
driving around
framing themselves as the victims of
government tyranny
and as
their convoy started to come east from
the west coast
russia invades ukraine
civilians are being killed it's a
complete violation of the sovereignty of
ukrainian borders etc etc
and these truckers are trying to say
they're the ones that are being
victimized by tyranny like it's what's
happening in ukraine is
absolutely horrifying just one of the
most one of the most horrible things
that's happened in the last couple of
years
but there's some hilarious irony to the
fact that when there are real victims of
government authoritarianism i'm talking
about ukrainian victims of putin's
authoritarianism
and belligerence
you've got truckers who are like i don't
want to get vaccinated i don't want to
get vaccinated the big headlines from
the trucker convoy about a week ago
someone on a bicycle got in front of the
convoy
and almost shut the entire thing down
they didn't even know how to get around
the biker
and um it barely got any attention they
accomplished nothing and the entire
uh reason for being
was bogus given the reduction in all
sorts of different mask vaccine and
testing requirements in the united
states let's hope that we're closing the
book on this pathetic excuse for
activism that is actually just a waste
of everyone's time and particularly
inconvenient to people who are just
trying to get to work and earn a living
one of the things we did not get to
cover yesterday when we covered the
wacky weekend in georgia with trumpists
and marjorie taylor greene and matt
gates and all of these other people was
that uh john bachmann a newsmax host i'm
not i'm not very familiar with john
bachman
john bachman was allowed i guess to
interview donald trump right before his
speech on saturday
it is a bizarre interview trump looks
visibly confused he doesn't seems
disoriented and the things he's saying
make just as little sense as trump's
physical appearance let's take a look at
this trump just uncontrollably lying and
even seems confused about the lies he's
telling let's talk about this lawsuit
against hillary clinton what do you hope
to accomplish with that well they
spotted my campaign you had all of them
there remember there is still no proof
that anybody spied on his campaign all
the names are there all the names you've
been reading about for years bill barr
didn't want to be impeached and so
therefore he decided not to do it which
was a shame because frankly you know you
need courage to fight these people deep
state or whatever you want to call them
but
trump's still talking about the deep
state i mean fully in to so many of
these different conspiracy theories i
think we're going to do very well with
it we have a great lawsuit and
i felt it was really very important to
bring it because
think of it if i spied on their campaign
can you imagine what would happen john
now remember the lawsuit as we talked
about yesterday will go nowhere if the
lawsuit were to proceed
trump would be subject to discovery and
the last thing trump would ever allow
is for himself to be put under oath and
deposed it's just the lawsuit's going
nowhere you guys know that spied on
their campaign on obama or biden or in
hillary clinton
and the same thing happened where we
caught him because we caught him
red-handed
if that ever happened
what are they talking about treason are
they talking about the rest of your life
in jail are they talking about death
penalty
and these people can't be allowed to get
away with this right so trump uh trump
suggesting that something that didn't
happen
is actually treason trump then seemingly
blaming joe biden
for putin
may be using nukes this is bizarre stuff
let's also talk about russia and ukraine
seems like uh putin may have
miscalculated there what is your
assessment of where things stand right
now with putin's invasion of ukraine
well you never know i can tell you the
country is just in shambles you look at
these cities they've been bombed and
they've been blown up and it's going to
take 50 to 100 years to rebuild them
and so many people have been killed so
many people have been killed and
horribly
wounded but i will tell you that
it should have never happened this would
have never happened had the election not
been rigged this would have never
happened he would have never in a
million years have done it so
it's very sad when i watch it it's sad
because
this is something all those people
should be living now they should not be
dead do you think putin would use
nuclear weapons
when you put them into a corner and when
you talk the way they're talking you
know they're talking weak and yet
they're almost giving him an incentive
it's
handling him very badly in my opinion
i think that biden apologized again
today he's apologized every time he
makes a speech he apologizes
three four times a day for everything he
says look
we have people that don't know what
they're doing yeah so anyway if if putin
uses nuclear weapons it is not going to
be joe biden's fault and then lastly
trump commenting on approval ratings i
have no idea if he's going to run i
can't imagine he does well he's got the
lowest approval rating in history in the
history of a president
which is pretty low and
if he does
and if i decide i'd love to run against
him i can tell you who would be better
now of course
donald trump's approval ratings at this
point in his presidency were lower than
those of joe biden so quite literally
all lies it's lies all the way down
and trump just is seeming very confused
when you look at him and when you listen
to him it's all very bizarre
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p our friend billy
harrison called in he really thinks
keystone xl would lower gas prices
listen to this
david pac-man yeah
billy harrison again
you're saying
president biden or any president for
that matter
has nothing to do
with the price of gas almost nothing to
do i've explained the three things
presidents can do
so
i've called you several times to debate
seems like you never play my
i i actually have played a number of
billy's clips a voicemail on your show
i wouldn't either about you because i
make you look stupid right
but your spending president has nothing
to do with gas prices
yet
joe biden first day in office counts for
keystone pipeline
that's one way he affects the gas prices
yeah no unfortunately that's not true
remember uh keystone pipeline phases one
through three are up and running what
joe biden did was stop construction of
the fourth phase of keystone xl
keystone is not an oil field it's only a
pipeline it's a way to transport the oil
the oil is still coming in it's just
coming in through other means and the
best estimates we have are that phase
four of keystone xl when completed and
it wouldn't even be done now
if biden had started
continued construction it wouldn't even
be done now but when completed
phase four of keystone xl would only
have increased oil production by one
percent would have no impact on the
price of gas sorry billy we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpackman.com
to get instant access i will see you
then